خصومات النهائيه لا تقدمها المتاجر
لعملائها الذين ينتظرون يوم الجمعه
السوداء كل عام في سباق عالمي لزياده
المبيعات والترويش وفيما يفضل البعضات
التسوق في المتاجر يلجا اخرون الى تسوق
عبر الانترنت هذه سنه ياتينا تحذير قوي
لمتسوقين عبر الانترنت لان اليوم تسوق
الشهير يمكن ان يكون مناسبه غير مسبوقه
لاكبر عمليه تنصيب عبر الانترنت تقريرنا
شرته الصحافه الامريكيه ذكر ان محتالين
يستغلون هذا اليوم لاطلاق حملات التصيد
الخداع المستخدمين والتسليم اسماءهم
وكلمات المرور الخاصه بها كما يكثف
القراصنه مؤخرا مساء السحب معلومات بطاقه
الدفع من خلال الصفحه المضلله التي
يشاءونها
يذكر انها مواقع تسوق الالكتروني العربيه
بدات عام 2014 باطلاق يوم الجمعه السوداء
مطلقه على الجمعه البيضاء بسبب خصوصيه يوم
الجمعه لدى المسلمين الى لميس وقصه اكبر
لهذه المناسبه في السنه
تعود قصه الجمعه السوداء الى الازمه
الماليه في الولايات المتحده عام
1869 والتي شكلت ضربه كبرى للاقتصاد
الامريكي حيث تحدثت البضائع وتوقفت حركه
البيع والشراء ما سبب هذه الاقتصاديه في
امريكا تعافت منها عن طريق اجراء تخفيضات
الكبرى على السلع والمنتجات لبيعها وتقليل
الخسائر قدر المستطاع ومنذ ذلك اليوم اصبح
تقليد في امريكا تقوم كبرى المتاجر والمحل
والوكلات باجراء تخفيضات كبرى على
منتجاتها تصل الى 90% من قيمتها في تعود
بعد ذلك اليوم الى سعرها الطبيعي بعد
انقضاءه
اما وصف هذا اليوم باللون الاسود فقد
اعطيت هذه التسميه اول مره في عام 1960 من
قبل الشرطه مدينه فيلادلفيا حيث كانت تظهر
اختناقات مروريه كبيره وتجمع وطوابير
طويله امام المحلات فالطوابير الطويله
والزحام المتدافع والسما الاساسيه للجمعه
السوداء في وصفت اداره الشرطه في مدينه
فيلادلفيا هذاك اليوم بالجمعه السوداء
لوصفه تلك الفوضى والازدحامات في حركه
المرور من مشاهير وسيارات
والمحاسبه حيث يدل على الربح والتخلص من
الموجود في المستودعات بينما يعبر اللون
الاحمر على الخساره والعجز اما المرجح
واستخدام الحبر الاسود لتسجيل الارباح
والحبر الاحمر لتسجيل الخسائر في دفتر
حسابات الارباح والخسائر اليوميه
الامريكيه وكانتيجه لتحقيق ارباح كبيره في
ذلك اليوم وامتلاء الدفاتر باللون الاسود
تم تسميته بالجمعه السوداء
[موسيقى]
في فقره الجانب الاقتصادي تنضم الى
الصحفيه والاعلاميه في قسم اقتصاد سمر
اهلا بك صباح الخير الموضوع
من حيث التخفيضات وكيف نختار الخسومات
هناك
اون لاين فقط هو اللي يشهد خصومات اكبر
هوبر البارحه كان في دراسه عن شركه ويتش
تقول انه بالحقيقه فقط خصوصا بلاك فرايدي
في امريكا هناك من كل سفن ديزل من كل سبع
صفقات صفقه واحده حقيقيه فقط اللي عليها
ديسكانت والباقي كلها تم زياده اسعاره
ورجعوا حتى وخصومات عليها هذا الشركه
اتراقب اكثر من 200 منتج على موجوده في
متاجر مختلفه وعلى الاون لاين خلال سته
اشهر وتشوف ايش قد تتغير سعرها وفعليا
كانت اسعارها ارخص في ايام اخرى غير
البلاك فرايد طب سمر اليوم الناس يعني
وضعها المادي مش باحسن احواله
القدره الشرائيه للفرده راجعت وحتى العالم
بشكل عام تضخم ورفع سعرها كل هذه الامور
راح تكون توقعات من حيث حجم المبيعات هذه
المره حجم المبيعات العام طبعا
اكثر من ثلاثه عشر في المئه كان يعني ها
اللي ب 20 21 بس هذا العام يتوقع انه يمه
شويه بس ماكسيمام 8 الى 960 مليار دولار
هذه في احسن احوال انفاق الفرد معدل انفاق
الفرد عالميا هيكون تقريبا العام كان بين
همم 300 الى 500 دولار هذا العام الاشخاص
يرون اجره في امريكا اجره دراسه شركه عدس
انه الافراد ينون همم معظمهم انفاق ماء
الى 200 دولار همم
ونسبه قليله الانفاق 200 الى 300 ولكن لن
نشهد الارقام باي بالفرد الواحد اللي
شاهدناها اللي كانت توصل الى 500 العام
الماضيين بحكي عن البائعين ما اهميه موسم
التخفيضات بالنسبه للبائع يعني هو الموسم
كله موسم الاعياد اللي هي طبعا عندك كرسمس
عمان يعني خصوصا في الخارج وحتى هنا طبعا
التسوق والهدايا وهذا اهم موسم بالنسبه
للبائعين لماذا لانه اقتربنا على نهايه
السنه لما تطلع الم بهذه الفصل الاخير لما
تطلع المبيعات هذا يعطي نظره ايجابيه عن
الشركه وبالتالي ترتفع اسهم الشركه اذا
نزلت المبيعات هذا هذه الفتره هي اسوا
فتره امازو وتقول هذه اسوا فتره في
تاريخها هذا العام بسبب تراجع الانفاق
ايضا هناك شركات عده كوز تارجت كلها نازله
اسهمها بسبب تراجع المبيعات فهذه الفتره
تعد اندكيتر على صحه هذه الشركه او مؤشر
على صحه هذه الشركه وبالتالي اسهمها فلما
تنزل ابنهايه السنه هتتاثر على سهم الشركه
بعدين اهو وفي فلسفه تتعلق بالبلاك فرايدي
بتقول انه هي فرصه للمتسوقين وحيله
للبائعين لانهم بيبيعوا كل المنتجات بسعر
كثير عالي خلال السنه فبالتالي انه خلص
يلا بنبيعها لبعض
المنتجات ونكون قبل قبل ما تبلش الديسكاو
هذه الفتره بنحاول ناخذ يعني احنا عملنا
انا صحباتي سكرين شوت على الاشياء وجبتنا
خذي لها سكرين شوت وخليها وشوفي شكد تتغير
هل تتغير السعر فعلا بعد بلاك فرايدي ان
طلعوا رجعوا ونزله وهفته عجب ان نكون
اذكياء صحيح ههه